hallo liebe leute heute ist mal wieder
ein regnerischer sonntag hier in berlin
und wir sind trotzdem motiviert auf die
straße gegangen um für euch ein video zu
drehen
und da wir gerade in einer kalten
jahreszeit leben haben wir gedacht wir
machen und zwar ein paar warme gedanken
und haben das thema ausgewählt was ist
dein traum urlaub oder eine traumreise
jetzt geht's auch schon los viel spaß
beim video
[Musik]
was wäre ihre traumreise eine traumreise
die tour zu fahren ich mir durch meine
traumreise das ist eine sehr gute frage
das ist eigentlich immer italien warum
weil ich die malerei war sind ich liebe
die architektur nicht jetzt dann zu aber
ich bin ich liebe die renaissance sehr
und die ist sehr verbreitet
ich würde am liebsten einmal um die welt
dann geht es die traumreise vielleicht
mit einem boot allein oder mit anderen
seiten später mit der familie will ich
sagen einmal nach alaska
warum sollen wir denn nach alaska ja es
ist interessiert mich einfach diese
diese einsamkeit die natur die tiere
einfach alles ich glaube ich würde
lieber so schön war fernwanderwegen dann
so von hütte zu hütte mit dem hund und
ja so ein bisschen regen
das werde ich ganz egal welches land
schwebt die da so vor augen so
nordengland schottland
schwer zu sagen aus dem stegreif
ich war viel ich habe mir einen
südamerika ich glaube ich würde gern
nach mexiko als nächstes zentral amerika
und darum greifen meint ramona wäre
auf jeden fall freunde besuchen im land
war nämlich wollen oder nicht war und
dann mit denen das gemeinsame kunden
entspannt irgendwo sitzen sich
geschichten erzählen nicht zu sehr zum
großes volles programm mehr entspannt
kein es muss nicht unbedingt historisch
was ganz besonderes sein einfach
irgendwo was nett ist und auf jeden fall
wärmeres wetter welches land könnte das
sein
oder welche region irgendwas
südeuropäisches oder vielleicht
lateinamerika
das ist schön warm jetzt das kann
vielleicht besser funktionieren was wäre
da eine traumreise einmal durch die usa
jedem bundesstaat einmal sehen würdet
ihr eure traumreise lieber alleine
machen oder lieber mit anderen also ich
würde sagen zusammen er hier zutritt
es ist ja einmalig auf diesen hund
vielleicht ist es fertig man hat dir das
letzte mal urlaub gemacht
also rauf oder seit einem jahr oder so
da wird es ja im juli als wir mit dem
interrail gefahren sind
dann würden sie das letzte mal nach
italien gereist letztlich ja schon jedes
jahr da ja und wo da genau
rom ist mein schönstes ja aber auch in
die sprache ich habe die sprache waren
sie mich wann hatten sie das letzte mal
urlaub
ich hatte jetzt ja zwischen weihnachten
und neujahr urlaub oder parks spannende
tage gemacht
wir machen gerade urlaub in berlin für
drei tage aber den letzten richtigen
urlaub hat man letztes jahr im
august immer wusste mai waren in polen
also urlaub ich hatte ziemlich glücklich
war ein halbes jahr habe ich in chile
studiert und einreichen halbes jahr
reisen also ich hatte quasi ist die
komplette wird sie urlaub dann machen
sie das nächste mal urlaub
das weiß ich noch nicht ich gebe mein
freund in madrid besuch am mittwoch das
bisschen wie urlaub entdecken sie das
sind dieses jahr wieder nach italien
fahren
naja ich hoffe im nächsten monat sie
denn das letzte mal urlaub machen die
richtigen oder ich gebe mal soviel paar
tage weg steht schon was an für die
nächsten wochen also die nächsten wochen
urlaub dann also nicht so urlaub wird
zum kitesurfen gehen in einem guten
kumpel unter freue ich mich schon drauf
und wohin geht's da nach spanien und
denken sie dass sie dieses jahr ihre
traumreise schon verwirklichen könnten
wir wollen dieses jahr erfüllen wir uns
eine andere traumreise da fahren wir
nach schottland
aber auch ein traum von uns näher weil
ich erst vor einem halben jahr
zurückgezogen wenn das könnte es
bisschen südeuropa vielleicht ja
lateinamerika wahrscheinlich er nicht
dieses jahr mehr
und denken sie wenn sie ihre traumreise
verwirklichen würden würden sie alleine
fahren oder lieber mit nach dem anderen
leuten schwer zu sagen
teils teils also ich mit
eigentlich auch gerne reisen aber auch
gern mit meiner freundin müssen wir
sehen 22 reisen und wer das dann erst
eine also würden sie mit dem rucksack
reisen oder was für eine art von urlaub
wäre das auto oder wohnmobil ist immer
ein mischmasch aus kultur spaß tanzen
essen unterhalten auch für mich sein
großes gemisch und wenn sie jetzt nach
mexiko reisen würden und dass er
sozusagen ihre traumreise wäre was wäre
das für eine art von urlaub also er
seinen reisen oder wellness oder
entspannung oder wandern
ich glaube das wäre wieder im
backpacking trip also so alles was man
mitnehmen kann viel kultur viel natur so
ja auf jeden fall in einem wenig habe
ich auch schon öfter gemacht einfach so
eine rundreise machen und am besten auch
ohne jetzt zeitliche eingrenzung also so
viel zeit nehmen wie man halt braucht es
halt schwierig mit dem job aber ich habe
meinen job vielleicht sogar dafür
kündigen und dann einfach los und ich
brauche auch nicht so viel also mit dem
rucksack und wie sieht urlaub hat diesem
jahr nicht genug 12 vielleicht also
einer von zweiter und damit die familie
was ist genommen und so weiter was ist
denn urlaub also jetzt mal die frage
muss man da verreisen gesagt haben was
einer tour auch zu hause also soll also
laut arbeitgeber 30 tage für den
jugendstil und ansonsten ja
schon so zweimal 300 jahre keine
ausflüge und wie viel urlaub haben sie
insgesamt zum jahr
ich habe angefangen zu arbeiten deswegen
ist das nach einer sehr ich habe laut
plan 27 urlaubstage
mal schauen wie ich diese verbringen
werde
dass unser video zum thema traumreise
oder traumurlaub wenn ihr gerade an
einem schöneren wärmeren ortszeit und
ihr euch schon gedanken gemacht habt
welche reise ihr demnächst machen wald
oder an gehen wollt dann schreibt das
auch gerne und in die kommentare
wenn ihr noch mehr übung zu dieser
episode oder zu diesem thema haben wollt
dann werdet gerne ein mitglied von the
german denn dann bekommt ihr jede woche
interaktive übungen vokabel listen und
transkripte und ja das war schon für
heute und wir wünschen euch noch ein
schönes warmes wohliges wochenende und
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]